Earlier on in the ChatGPT section,
we had a look at how we can easily generate images
from prompts and also by using reference images.
Now, I want to also make a point here
that ChatGPT Vision also has reasoning capabilities.
So for example, we can put in the original portrait
of my image and we can ask a question like,
how many fingers am I holding up?
And ChatGPT is able to not only generate images
from images, but it's also able to provide you
with cognitive reasoning on specific images.
So now ChatGPT is analysing the images
and it shows us that we're holding up two fingers
in a classic peace sign.
Let's also have a look on Google.
So I'm going to go and get an image
of several men working in the world
and seeing if it can identify both the gender
and how many people there are in this image.
So then I'm going to go back to ChatGPT,
I'm going to click on the plus sign,
upload from computer, going to go into my downloads,
and then I'm going to say,
how many people are in this image
and what gender are they?
Okay, so ChatGPT has worked out
that there are two people in the image.
So it can't really identify the gender,
but it has been able to identify that there are two people.
We could also tell ChatGPT to give this
in more of a structured data form.
So I could say, could you output this as a CSV
with probabilities for male versus female
and the number of people identified.
And then we can get structured data directly out
from ChatGPT and we're just reasoning over those images.
So again, you can see here,
it's worked out that this is how much
it likely thinks the probability of male is
versus the probability of female.
And then it's basically making a CSV
and then it shows us we can download
this specific CSV here.
So I've now got some structured data.
So you've got these person IDs,
the estimated gender is unknown,
but the probability of male is quite high.
And there you go.
Okay, so I'd recommend having a play around with this,
maybe add in a couple of images
and try and get some structured data out from these images.
That could include identifying different types of objects,
people, places, or emotions.
Cool, I'll see you in the next one.